ils sont commerçants ou encore artisans
et les habitent en ville ou à la
campagne
depuis la crise du coronavirus des
millions de tunisiens et de tunisiennes
à travers tout le pays peine à joindre
les deux bouts des magasins fermés des
cafés fermés des commerces fermés alors
comment font-ils pour vivre au quotidien
alors que les aides du gouvernement en
peine ta tombe et se soigner se protéger
du conte un virus certes mais à quel
prix c'est une journée bien calme pour
najet qui comme de nombreux tunisiens
elle tourne en rond dans sa maison en
espérant pouvoir retravailler un jour
depuis la révolution de 2011
ils sont nombreux comme l avoir ouvert
deux petits commerces pour faire face au
quotidien devenu difficile cette crise
du coronavirus elle le vit comme un
drame elle la mère de famille sur qui
reposent de nombreuses responsabilités
ce rideau cela fait quinze jours qu'elle
n'avait pas le dos je fais des galettes
des sandwichs j'ai même rajouté des
sodas et de l'eau depuis le coronavirus
on nous a demandé de fermer de ne plus
travailler pour éviter toute
contamination
on a fermé depuis quelques semaines
depuis aucune rentrée d'argent je
n'achète plus de produits je ne sais pas
du tout quand est ce que je pourrais
retourner travailler
on nous a simplement dit qu'il y aura
une aide pour ceux qui travaillent avec
une licence
même avec une licence qu'est ce qu'on
peut faire avec 200 dinars qu'est ce que
je vais faire avec si peu payé mon loyer
aider ma famille on peut rien faire avec
une telle somme
en plus ils ont promis cette somme mais
ils ne l'ont toujours pas versé soir
elle m'a dit je fais là loin de la
campagne dans la banlieue sud de tunis
c'est le même son de cloche tout comme
najet ils sont nombreux à avoir baissé
le rideau depuis le début de la crise du
corps navires us des cafés des
restaurants des bars ou encore être des
commerces
même scénario pour l'ensemble de ces
tunisiens un quotidien qui devient
pesant
surtout quand un seul revenu fait vivre
toute une famille pour mohamed ali cela
fait quinze jours que ces ciseaux sont
rangés dans le placard puis le client
donc un manque de revenus considérables
pour faire vivre sa femme et ses deux
enfants est tellement votre salon ici
voici mon salon soyez bienvenue cette
année
vous voyez il est bien vide mais je suis
pas le seul dans cette situation on est
tous pareils
j'espère juste que ça va pas durer car
si la situation venait à durer
c'est tout un pays qui va s'arrêter et
la criminalité risque d'augmenter
l'intérêt des musulmanes et un trader
il ya beaucoup de personnes qui n'ont
rien et beaucoup ne travaille pas et
pour ceux qui travaillent
c'est au jour le jour l'argent commence
à manquer moi j'ai un peu d'argent de
côté mais combien de temps ça va me
tenir et vous avez peur de ça des
travaux est bien sûr que j'ai peur de ça
tout le monde a peur de ça c'est la
préoccupation de tout le pays c'est un
drame pour moi comme pour l'ensemble du
pays
si tout s'arrête on craint qu'une crise
éclate et l'église mahler plus de 50000
commerces ont été contraints de fermer
depuis le début de la crise du corona
virus alors que le gouvernement tunisien
a promis de débloquer une enveloppe de
plus de 100 millions d'euros pour venir
en aide aux ménages les plus modestes
les tunisiens et craignent une crise
sociale et économique
si le confinement venait à durer dans le
temps